ANDREW BROGDON: Hey,
everybody, and welcome
to the first episode of
the "Mobile Ads Garage,"
where we cover the nuts and
bolts of mobile ads code
in a format that's just like
my grandma-- short and sweet.
I'm Andrew Brogdon,
a developer programs
engineer with the Google
Mobile Ads SDK team.
We've heard from a
lot of our publishers
that you'd love more
technical content.
So we're here to get our hands
dirty, to wire things up, turn
them on, and see how they work.
We'll have screencasts
of real code, hack
on real applications,
and, with the help
of my intrepid partner,
Gary the graphics guy,
we'll show you the results.
So if you've ever taken a look
at the AdMob documentation
and thought, that's
great, but could you
have a ginger explain
it to me in a format I
can watch on my phone,
turns out we can do that.
For our first
episode, we're going
to focus on how easy it is
to get started with the SDK.
Let's imagine that I'm in
an application-- exactly.
One of the simplest
ways to monetize an app
is just by adding a banner.
But there's also
interstitial ads like these,
or even native ads like these.
The one thing all these
formats have in common
is the Mobile Ads SDK.
Properly importing and
referencing it in your project
is step one.
So let's take a look
at how to do it.
We'll start with iOS.
So here we are in Xcode with
a very simple Hello World app
that I'd like to
import the SDK into.
So how do I do it?
Well, here are the steps.
I'll be using CocoaPods today.
So the first step is to
create or update the PodFile.
Then I'll run pod install,
which will download the SDK
and integrate it
into the project.
And then I'll open the workspace
file that CocoaPods creates.
And I'll be right back
in Xcode ready to go.
So here I am in the root
directory of my Xcode project.
And I'm going to open the
PodFile in a text editor.
And I'm going to
drop in some text.
If you're familiar
with CocoaPods,
this should look
really familiar to you.
The important part is
this line right here.
That tells CocoaPods
that the project
has a dependency on version
7.0 or higher of the Mobile Ads
SDK.
So I'll save this.
And then I'll run
pod install, which
will download the SDK
automatically and integrate it
into my project.
And as you can see, we've got
a lot more stuff in this folder
now.
So I'm going to open
up that workspace file.
And now I'm right back in Xcode.
And just like any
other framework,
I can use an import
statement to reference it
in one of my files.
And now that I
have GADBannerView,
which is an AdMob class,
it's properly recognized.
So you know the SDK is in here.
We try to make it as easy
as possible to integrate
mobile ads.
Time is money, and we're all
about keeping costs down.
For example, the garage
behind me-- that's
not even a real garage.
This is, like, a
holodeck situation.
Watch, I could be
in outer space.
Or I could be swimming
with the dolphins.
I could even be backstage
with Justin Bieber
if I wanted to be.
Gary, get it-- oh.
Legal didn't approve
the-- so I shouldn't even
do the Bieber joke at all?
Well, legal fees aside, we
try to keep costs down so
we can keep your revenue up.
Let's take a look at importing
the SDK into an Android Studio
project.
OK, so here I am in Android
Studio with a Hello World app
that I'd like to
get the SDK into.
So what are the steps?
For Android, there is just two.
First, I'll update the
app's build.gradle file
to add a dependency
on Mobile Ads.
Then I'll do a Gradle
sync, and I'm ready to go.
OK, here's my build.gradle.
And I'm going to go to
the dependency section
and add a line.
That's right down here.
The Google Mobile Ads SDK is
part of Google Play services.
So what we're doing is telling
Gradle to pull in just the ads
code with play-services-ads.
And the numbers at the
end are the version.
You should always try
to use the latest one.
Now that that's done, I'm
going to do a Gradle sync.
That's where Gradle pulls in all
the resources my project needs,
checks all the references, and
makes sure everything's OK.
If this is the first time you've
used Google Play services,
Android Studio might
pop up a window
and ask you to download
something called the Google
Repository.
If that happens, don't worry.
That's just Android
Studio and Gradle
downloading the SDK for you.
OK, now that we've
finished the Gradle sync,
let me come back to
my activity and try
to use one of the SDK's classes.
Here we go.
You can see it
automatically suggesting
the package and class,
so the SDK is definitely
in the project now.
So that's it.
Getting the SDK into a
project is the first step
toward displaying ads
and earning revenue.
In our next video,
we'll cover how
to use the SDK to
display banners
on both iOS and Android.
In the meantime, I've got
some great resources for you,
like our AdMob Quick
Starts for iOS and Android,
which have notes for Java,
Objective C, and Swift.
We also have sample
code up on GitHub
for both operating
systems, so check those out
if you're interested.
You might also like AdMob's
mobs no nonsense guide
to app monetization.
It's an overview of
monetization strategies
that includes code and
tips from other engineers.
If you've got a technical
question relating
to anything you've just seen,
stop by our support forum.
And if you've got a question
about this video series
or a tip on something
you'd like us to cover,
leave a comment below, and Gary
and I will see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]